بعد ما محاوله القتل امام المرحاض ايضا
صار في توجه سخوف يعني فهو كمان انكفى على
نفسه ولذلك قوقعه من طرفين يعني الخوف
منهم من ناحيه ومفروضه من الخارج من ناحيه
اخرى تمام الا من الثقب الا من الثقب
الثقب للمراقبه وليس للتواصل الانساني
ولكن كان يتم رؤيه كل عمليات الشمس
والاعدام والتعذيب من خلال هذا الثقب الذي
يرى من خلاله مغطيا راسه بالبطانيه
ليس من خوفا من الخارج خوفا من الداخل
الداخل حتى ما يعرف الناس انه هو شو عم شو
عم بيعمل يعني قبل ان ينفتح عليه بعض
صار في يعني قليل من الثقه
وبتصير متبادله يعني هو ايضا كشف السر
لبعض الناس داخل المهاجع انه انا اراقب ما
يجري خارج المهجر وخاصه حفلات الاعدام
تخيلت ان عناصر الشرطه العسكريه ذو وجوه
مسلوخه ايه قوه سلخت هذه الوجوه كيف سلخت
لماذا اين لست ادري لكن ما اراه ان الوجوه
البديله لا تشبه وجوه باقي البشر وجوه
اهلنا واصدقائنا مسح غير بشريه هي غير
مرئيه صحيح ولكنها قطعا موجوده
كيف كنت تتعامل مع هؤلاء التعامل مع
المحقق في بدايه مجيئك الى الاعتقال وقصه
الاعتقال شيء والتعامل بعدين مع السجانه
العاديين شيء اخر السجان العاديين هو مجرد
عباره عن اله غير انسانيه
وظيفته الوحيده في هذا المكان هو انه
يعذبك ويقتلك فاي استشداء او اي
تضرع او يعني محاوله الثليين مستحيله يعني
بتصيح يعني مثلا
بسموها حلاوه الروح يعني وقت بتكون تعاني
الام شديده جدا مبرحه من هذا تستنجد
تستنجد بالله تستنجد بمحمد تستنجد
بعضهم كان مثلا مشان الله مشان حافظ اسد
على اساس انهم يعني هذا كان يزيد التعذيب
بمعنى وذاكره انا انه اسم حافظ الاسد
اتوسخ واطلع من تم هذا السجل
فعمليه كنا كلياتنا واعينا انه هاي عمليه
غير مجديه ولذلك اي استجداء يعني هو يعني
[موسيقى]
غير مبرر